welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul joined by Master tment
we've just obviously had a massive
breaking story the last 24 hours I'm
getting up at half 4 in the morning to
do this I don't know what time it is for
you but you're looking great it's
midnight and a half well that's not too
bad um but yeah I thought we'd just go
over the whole Jonathan major situation
when I made my video last night I was
thinking right they're going to give it
a couple of hours before they announced
something else didn't even give it that
it was literally within the next hour
that they announced that Jonathan made
was out and then since then we've had
even more news on the developing story
so what was your initial reaction to
that cuz I was completely shocked yeah
it's kind of crazy you know like you
know knowing that you know Jon the
majers was going to be this huge part of
the MCU and then for Marvel Studios to
be like all right we're going to
completely change our plans for Avengers
5 and like you know I I guess like now
like internally they're calling it
Avengers 5 and not King Dynasty anymore
it's absolutely just like mind-blowing
and like I'm very C curious to see how
Marvel Studios corrects I mean like we
sort of see what like their their plan
going forward with Loki and the Loki
season finale you know like how they
ended things with Victor timley and all
that stuff and and and basically Kang
not really forming in a lot of timelines
so yeah I'm very curious to see what
Marvel Studios does here because like
this is some massive news yeah Kang
dasty I saw someone say and then they
also said he who does not remain and I
was like come on man but looking at the
case this was actually it actually
started in March 25th of this year and
they've clearly been sitting on it for a
while I I didn't I totally didn't
realize how long ago it happened but
they they have clearly been biting their
time and just thinking we're going to
wait for the outcome of the trial and
then they had that they had that news
article saved in the drafts and ready to
go because as soon as a hit man that
that report just went out everywhere
yeah I'm just kind of still shocked
about it I think the press release was
ready it's got me thinking about phase
four and five in general and just how
much of a disaster that's been you know
in terms of audience reception there's
been several things that have happened
unfortunately Chadwick Bowman passed
away which they weren't obviously they
weren't planning on they didn't know
that was going to be happening and yeah
it's just they've had so much thrown at
them and it just makes me look back at
this phase and think gez that there's
been so many different stories that have
had to change the direction and they are
still apparently going with Michael
walren as the script writer for those
films but but right yeah it's it's kind
of all up in the air I personally think
that they should recast K I think
there's enough there that they can get
someone else in absolutely you know
Denzel Washington gets thrown around and
I do see a lot of Jonathan Maes in his
performances you know the way he can be
very bombastic and over the top and he
can kind of tone it down and be very
serious I think he could play an older
version of Kang like and mortis whether
he would want to do it though is another
thing entirely you know there's lots of
different actors that could come across
is there anyone that you think could
could fill the shoes of K I propose the
name uh was it David O oyao or Daniel o
ool I'm butchering his name I apologize
he was in um I think it was in Spooks
and um hold on one second I can get his
name I'm like edit this we can pretend
you I'm
sorry okay
no um no I was thinking David ooloo um
he's an uh like a really great actor
from I believe from uh from where you
are from Great Britain and um I think
that he would be a fantastic King Denzel
Washington's son um the dude that was an
in tenant um I feel like he would also
be fantastic but yeah no I feel like
there's a number of great options that
Marvel can do like so like outside of
like you know recasting King which is
like I feel like is the best decision
because like why not recast King you're
in a Multiverse narrative like there's
you can easily just write that in
universe and that everyone will believe
it so like that should be the option but
like outside of recast and Kang are
there any other villains that you would
like to see Marvel Studios tackle I mean
Dr Doom's the obvious one I don't know
how they're doing Secret Wars without Dr
Doom because but I mean both versions of
Secret Wars the 80s version the 2015
version they're both heavily centered
around Dr Doom and even when they
announced they were tackling those
stories but it was going to be with K I
was a bit like that's a bit strange so I
I would like to see them head in that
direction i' even got a little theory
about how they could do it um so you
have the Council of kangs I'd love to
see them open up the powers of the where
the beyonder is steal the powers of the
Beyond and then Doom comes down wipes
out the whole Council takes the power
for him himself and that kind of in a
narrative way at least sorts out why
Kang's not there anymore and leads into
Dr Doom whether they're going to go that
way I don't know I don't think they
watch this channel if they do then I'm
in a lot of trouble cuz I spoiled a lot
of their movies
but yeah that that's kind of how I can
see things going now it is quite strange
because K apparently according to the
report wasn't even the original
direction that they were going to be
heading with things and from what we
heard Jonathan Maes was so good on Loki
that they kind of thought oh we can
build the phase around him um so it
doesn't necessarily feel like Kang was
always the plan whether they're going to
do two Avengers movies in the way that
they were going to do Kang Dynasty and
then Secret Wars is another thing
entirely I actually think if they decid
to drop K they should go in a civil war
Direction and we have heard rumors that
Spider-Man 4 is going to be that sort of
thing in Civil War I it kind of happens
around the The Secret Wars time in the
comics as well I was thinking right and
this is I don't know if they're going to
do this because the Marvels didn't
perform well but I was thinking Captain
Marvel 3 the way to save that character
is to have Captain Marvel 3 be Civil War
2 and then bring in Spider-Man or some
you know what I mean I mean she's big in
the comment in case you guys haven't
read Civil War I it's basically Tony
Stark versus Captain Marvel um they have
someone come in who's an inhuman who can
predict the the future by having some
algorithm built in his head spoiler on
that but he there's two sides to it with
one person being like well who's Captain
Marvel who's like this is a cured to all
our problems we can finally we can
basically do pre- crime and predict
everything that's coming and Tony
Stock's sort of thinking well the crime
hasn't happened yet and we're damning a
lot of people and for example the Hulk
gets killed because of it um because the
guy basically has the prediction that
the Hulk will eventually destroy
everything at some point which is a
totally fair assumption to make um so
yeah yeah I would say
so yeah they kind of go in that
direction with it um and I think that
could add some real dramatic Stakes to
Captain Marvel 3 and then lead into
maybe a big Avengers Secret Wars 2 event
and it just kind of steers them away
from
the controversial aspects that are part
of this case because I think this
probably will hang over the MCU for
quite a while yeah no for sure like for
sure for sure and like I really like
that idea of them doing a Civil War II
scenario now because like they sort of
have the seeds of that um already
established in the MCU because like
remember project Insight from uh Captain
America 2 like that technology of them
like sort of like predicting the future
using an algorithm to sort of like
predict future criminals that's already
MCU can so they could just use that like
Zola's algorithm be like all right let's
just do Civil War I without the need for
like the inhuman guy that can see the
future which is like a really
interesting part of that that narrative
U but like I really like the Minority
Report aspect of Civil War II a lot and
like I think that that would be a great
idea yeah I mean like you said I didn't
even realize it was built into the
universe and the the heroes are getting
to that point now where they're getting
hit every other week with some world
ending threat and yeah going into that I
also think that obviously the way the
Marvel's left things that Avengers
versus X-men could be a thing coming
down the line bro I feel like that
should be the like if that's not on
Kevin feig's mind you should that should
be in his mind immediately right now
because Avengers versus X-men especially
like on the road to Secret Wars like
that I feel like that Showdown would
sell so many tickets because everyone
would want to see the fox era X-Men
against the like modern day Avengers to
see who would win like that's like I
feel like everyone has that conversation
like you know it's like that barber shop
conversation it's like all right who
would win like wver could totally take
down like you know the the current
roster of Avengers so like I feel like
that should be the move for Marvel um if
they're looking to Pivot I apologize one
second curse you Alexa damn you Alexa
Alexa stop I'm so sorry I totally forgot
to shut that off ruin the
video uh but yeah no I feel like I
totally lost my train of thought I
apologize the machine taking over
that'll be foggy on the other end
listening to all our little discussions
and writing down little notes right now
seriously hold on one second I have I
set up I set up two alarms for 12:30
a.m. and I totally forgot to turn them
off one second a few moments later you
know whatever they decide to do with the
future like I feel like it has to be
very much on that
multiversal level so I feel like you
need a multiversal villain to um sort of
take the place of Kang so I wonder how
like who they're going to choose for
that because you don't have to feel bad
your alarm went off you
know people at my they don't care yeah
they don't care about
that so we've had Daniel rpk actually as
well just drop a big thing about what
he's heard behind the scenes is
happening and he said that Kang dynasty
was set to film in March in the UK and
walren had been hired in November to
write a new draft at the time Mages was
still attached to the script so was
still very much about K and the idea
with with Waldren coming on board
according to rpk was to finish what he
started with Loki now they said that if
he was found not guiltyy they would have
kept him and gone in that direction
whether there was bad press or not um
but just with the verdict they've been
left with no choice and though they
haven't fully decided the next steps
that they have decided to let go of
Mages at the very least so yeah I can
see why they would move away as well
because I think Mages kind of is very
memorable and I think it would
hang over that role the entire time and
it might be something that people talk
about every time it's brought up and if
you're discussing Kang it's it's he's
probably going to get brought up as well
now I know a lot of people are like well
how come we had controversy with Jeremy
Rena and nothing happened to him and I
think it was because it was purely
because of this verdict and you could
see as soon as the the press release
went out that it was bouncing off the
back of that to to be fair to
Marvel
sorry I know it's so bad I've lost my
Traer thought but I was going to say
something good it's okay don't you worry
any final thoughts um I think that like
they should like there's a number of
directions that they could potentially
take things I think they could they
could go Red Skull because we know in
what if that like Red Skull was
beginning to come like to become more of
a multiversal villain with his uh
experiments with the tessaract and like
the weird tentacle creatures so they can
do that they could do killmonger
Infinity because I feel like a lot of
people love kilmonger and they wanted to
come back so like that what if version
of konger would be great but yeah I I
feel like you know there's there's a
number of options that they could
potentially go to but uh no no I'm just
you know it's just very interest it's a
very interesting time to be a comic book
fan and it's a very interesting time for
Marvel so like I'm very interested to
see what uh what Kevin figy ends up
doing and like what they end up
announcing in the replacement as a
replacement to King Dynasty well you
sound very interested in it
yeah it it has happened at a very bad
time for Marvel just with the way that
interest in the franchise at the moment
they've obviously just had secret
Invasion earlier in the a which was
their lowest rated show um the Marvels
has been their lowest performing MCU
movie and now this on top of it I mean I
wouldn't even be surprised if they
decided to just be like we need to just
pump the brakes on
everything have Deadpool 3 come out and
then really start to assess where we're
going to take things what if is dropping
on Friday then Echo is after that we're
going to see what happens with those but
um yeah a lots of things going down in
the future and thank you for you guys
rocking with us um like I said it's very
late for Mt very early for me we're kind
of meeting halfway um I am planning on
doing more of these with you if you're
if you're down for it yes and yeah I'd
love to just because I was like why
haven't we we just started doing videos
we talk about stuff didn't make sense um
but yeah good having you on board
hopefully you guys enjoyed our little
talk about what what our initial
theories are and what could happen um we
did kind of want to skirt around the the
cour case if you want to see a breakdown
of that that's on the channel right now
um so yeah go ahead over there after
this and huge thank you for watching it
and yeah thank you Mt for joining me
much love everyone same take it easy
[Music]
guys